the national requirement for travelers
to wear a mask on planes and other
public transportation is due to expire
on monday meaning regulators need to
decide whether to extend it or end it
deadline is fast approaching and coveted
cases are surging again in parts of the
u.s but a lot of people are tired of
those masks errol barnett is at
washington's reagan national airport
errol i flew in and out of there just
yesterday wore my mask the whole time
didn't like it good morning
yep and that's the norm for now tony
good morning to you good morning to
everyone look one of the reasons this
has become such a flash point is that
where i'm standing now is one of the
last places where you still have to wear
a mask inside airports on planes and at
major transit hubs the mother travel
industry certainly is pushing the white
house to get rid of this rule
immediately the question remains if now
is the right time to lose travel masks
for good
it has been one of the most
controversial topics in american
aviation during the pandemic and a
trigger for violent passenger attacks
the current federal requirement to mask
while in transit expires april 18th but
some flyers think it's time for them to
decide to mask up or not they should
have gave the people a choice whether
they wanted to wear it or not
from the beginning i don't really care i
would continue wearing mine most
americans favor an extension a recent
survey finding six in ten support
staying masked while traveling the
industry though sees things differently
we need to remove these mandates roger
dow is president of the u.s travel
association
which along with three other industry
groups cite economic costs for pushing
the white house to end travel mass rules
for all we have an unpredictable virus
with many variants but we're seeing
again and again these variants are less
severe in their letter the group cites
cdc guidance that the overwhelming
majority of the country no longer needs
to wear masks indoors and the white
house says the cdc is still determining
its next move it's a decision made by
the cdc so they will make that a
decision and i'm not aware of a decision
being made at this point ali malice is
the government affairs rep for american
airlines flight attendant union health
and scientific data have to be
at the center at the core of any
decision going forward we all look
forward to the day when mass are no
longer needed but until that day it's
really important
that we're all cooperating
cooperation is key now the uk just might
be the canary in the coal mine here it
lost and dropped its travel restrictions
just last month and that included
heathrow airport losing its mass mandate
only to have british airways easyjet and
other carriers
cancel more flights than usual out of
london here over the last few weeks and
gail what do they cite for those issues
staffing shortages due to covid so
there's no real easy answers here i know
it really isn't easy errol thank you so
much
i don't know guys it just seems with the
covet cases going up it doesn't seem
like the right time but they will tell
you that the air the air in the planes
is very well circulated very well
circulated and and
experts will tell you that the the risk
of covid when you're traveling is more
in the airport or in the bus terminal or
train station than actually on the plane
or in the trains or different situation
but in the airport versus on the plane
but i do think that arrows point about
the uk being an interesting test subject
which is that they relaxed those
mandates and people got sick yes and so
they had to cancel flights because they
had no staff that's an interesting
development all i know is when i close
that door on the airplane i'm like ah
here we are so you're okay taking off
your mask on the plane i wish i could
because i i have i have what is i have a
big face and the mask is always
irritating the back of my ears because i
got you know why the long face charlie
brown no no you're right it's longer
it's not the round head okay that's me
i'm gonna leave mine on for now